so welcome to the machine translation
lecture which is kind of like a
culmination of this sequence of three
lectures on RN ends and related topics
so let's have a few announcements first
the first thing is this you probably
noticed when you came in we're taking
attendance today so you need to sign in
with the TAS who are outside the
auditorium if you missed it don't get up
now it's fine there'll be time to sign
in after the lecture and then if you
have any kind of questions about special
cases with the attendance policy you
should check out the piazza post that we
put up last night with some
clarifications you have the reminder is
assignment for content is going to be
covered today so you can have everything
you need to do a slide at 4:00 at the
end of stay and do get started early
because the model takes four hours to
train the other announcement is that
we're going to be sending out our
mid-quarter feedback survey sometime in
the next few days probably
so please do fill it out you'll get 0.5%
credit and you're also going to help us
to make the class better for the rest of
the quarter okay so here's the overview
of what we're going to do stay today
first we're going to introduce a new
task in NLP which is machine translation
and then we're going to introduce a new
neural architecture called sequence to
sequence and the connection here is that
machine translation is a major use case
of sequence sequence after that we're
going to introduce a new neural
technique called attention and this is
something that improves sequence the
sequence Ilan okay so section 1 of this
is going to be about a bit of machine
translation history pre neural machine
translation so machine translation or MT
is the task of translating a sentence X
which we call the source language
whatever language you're translating
from into a sentence Y which is in
another language which we call the
target language so here's an example
that suppose X is this French sentence
could anyone in the audience a French
speaker translate this to English for us
[Music]
everywhere he is great so that was
something like the man is born free but
every way he's anions that was a fairly
literal translation it's usually
translated this quote by Rousseau is
usually translated as man is born free
but everywhere he is in Chains but you
know there's an ambiguity should first
be literally ions or chains or so you
could choose to translate Lamas man or
maybe human kind
so this is an example of machine
translation and there's already you know
quite a few choices you can make
so the beginning of machine translation
is an AI task began in the early 1950s
so in particular there was a lot of work
translating Russian to English because
the West was very interested in
listening to what the Russians were
saying during the Cold War and we've got
a fun video here which shows the state
of machine translation in 1954 with
ambiguity when they set out to use
computers to translate languages
[Music]
Slate's Russia into English one of the
first non numerical applications of
computers it was the solution to the
human translators so in this video I
think there's a number of interesting
things firstly we can see an example of
about how AI hype is nothing new
even in 1954 they were talking this
machine translation system as if it was
an electronic crane which I think
overstates maybe how general it is they
were also at least some of them fairly
optimistic that this machine translation
system was going to be replacing humans
anytime soon so yeah that's that's
pretty interesting and the thing is that
these systems actually were mostly
rule-based
by which I mean that they were mostly
using a bilingual dictionary between
Russian and English and they were
essentially mostly just looking up the
Russian words looking at their English
counterparts and they were storing these
big bilingual dictionaries on these
large magnetic tapes so suddenly it was
a huge technical feat at the time but
they some people were probably too
optimistic about how quickly it would
replace humans so jumping forward
several decades in time now I want to
tell you about statistical machine
translation so the core idea of
statistical machine translation is that
you're going to learn a probabilistic
model from the data in order to do the
translation so as an example as before
suppose that we're translating from
French to English the idea is that you
want to find the best English sentence
why given the French sentence X and
mathematically you can formulate this as
finding Arg max Y of this conditional
probability of Y given X and the more
that you're learning is this probability
distribution P so what we usually do is
we break down this probability into its
two components using Bayes rule so this
means that finding the way that
maximizes probability of Y given X is
equivalent to finding the Y that
maximizes the probability of X given Y
times the probability of Y so the two
components here on the Left we have a
translation model and this is keeping
track of how words and phrases should be
translated so the idea is that it knows
how French words and an English words
might be translated to each other or
maybe small small phrases and chunks of
words should be translated and this is
learnt from a lot of parallel data and
I'll be telling you later how we do that
the second component P of y this is just
a language model we learned about this
last week a language model is a system
that can predict the next words but it
can also be thought of as a system that
tells you the probability of the
sequence of words so here if we're
translating from French to English P of
Y is an English language model so the
idea is that the reason why we want to
break down this single conditional
conditional probability distribution
into the product of two different ones
is that this is a kind of division of
labor the idea is that instead of a
single conditional probability
distribution you need to understand how
to translate and how to write good
English text and understand sentence
structure and everything at once the
idea is that you separate it so that the
translation model on the left in blue
mostly just knows about a local
translation of small chunks of words and
phrases whereas the language model on
the right Moore takes care of writing
good English good sentence structure
word order and so on so you already know
how to learn a language model because we
learned about that last time you just
need lots of monolingual data in this
case English data so I'm going to tell
you more about how we would learn this
translation model that needs to be
learnt from parallel data so we need a
large amount of parallel data in order
to learn this translation model and an
early example of a parallel corpus is
the rosetta stone so this is a stone
that has the same text written in three
different languages
and this is a hugely important artifact
for the the people who were trying to
understand ancient Egyptian so in the
19th century scholars discovered this
stone and it helped them to figure out
ancient Egyptians because there was this
parallel text that had the same the same
text in other languages that they did
know so this is a this is a really
important parallel corpus and if you're
ever in London you can go to the British
Museum and see this in person so the
idea is that you get your parallel data
obviously you need a larger Mountains on
the stone and hopefully it shouldn't be
written on a stone either but you can
use this to learn your statistical
machine translation model so the idea is
that you're trying to learn this
conditional probability distribution of
X given Y so what we do is we actually
break this down even further we actually
want to consider the probability of X
and a given Y where a is the alignment
so the idea of alignment is this is how
the words in the English sentence and
the French sentence correspond to each
other so I'm going to demonstrate this
by an example so in this example where
we're translating the sentence Japan
shaken by two knee quakes to French then
you can see there's a pretty simple
one-to-one alignment here of English
words two French words and also they
appear in the exact same order the only
thing that doesn't conform to that is
the word look in French which we call a
spurious word because it doesn't have a
direct counterpart in the English
sentence and that's because in English
we just say Japan but in French we say
lose your bomb so alignment can be a bit
more complicated than that
for example alignment can be many to one
in this example you have several french
words that have multiple English words
that correspond to them so this is what
we call many to one alignment it can go
in the other direction too alignment can
be one too many so here we have a single
English word implemented which has a
one-to-many alignment because there's a
three word French fit phrase that
corresponds to it so on the left and the
right we have two ways of depicting the
same alignment it's either a kind of a
chart or it can be a a graph
so here's another example of a
one-to-many
sorry right so we call this word
implemented that is one too many
we call it a fertile word because the
idea is that it has many children in the
in the target sentence so in fact there
are some words which are very fertile
here's an example where the source
sentence illa mont arte means he hit me
with a pie and here in french this verb
on tart a means to hit someone with a
pie and this word has no single words
equivalent in english we don't have a
single verb that means to hit someone
with a pipe which i think is really fun
the french house of words you want to
maybe they do it so often that they need
a single word for that i don't know
so this is an example of a fertile word
right because it needs to have several
corresponding english words to
translators so we can have once many and
many to one you can also have many to
many alignments you could call that kind
of phrase level translation of phrase to
phrase so here the English sentence says
the poor doesn't don't have any money
and here don't have any money
corresponds to the French phrase song
Domini and this is a many to many
alignments because there's no obvious
way to break down this phrase to phrase
alignment into smaller word to word
alignments okay so that's what alignment
is and if you remember we were thinking
about how would you learn this
probability distribution of what the
alignment is in order to do statistical
machine translation so the idea is that
you learn probability of X and a given Y
as a combination of many factors or many
features so you consider for example
what's the probability of a particular
word aligning to another particular word
like you know this english word of this
french word how often do they align but
then this also depends on for example
what's their position in the sentence
like if they both appear near the end of
the sentences then it's more likely that
they align whereas if one's at the
beginning and ones at the ends that's
less likely you would also consider
things like what's the probability of
this particular French word having this
particular fertility like what's the
probability of this word having three
corresponding in English
and so on so all of these statistics are
learnt from your parallel data and
there's many other things that you would
take into consideration so we're looking
at a kind of overview of statistical
machine translation today you're not
going to understand it in full detail
but we're understanding an overview of
how it works because we're going to be
comparing it to neural machine
translation okay so we're learning this
SMT system and so far we've broken it
down into these two main components
we've got the translation model and
we've got the language model and we
understand a little bit about how you
might learn this translation model by
breaking it down into alignments so a
question remains how do you do the arc
map server why how do you find your
french sentence why that maximizes this
probability so one kind of beautiful
solution is you could say let's
enumerate every possible Y that's kind
of every possible sequence of French
words maybe up to some length and we'll
calculate this probability for all of
them and it should be pretty clear that
that's just a no-go that's way too
expensive and we're not going to be able
to get anywhere with that so the answer
for how you actually do this in practice
is you're you're going to use some kind
of heuristic search algorithm to search
for the best translation Y but along the
way you're going to discard hypotheses
that are too low probability say okay
you're going to search but you're going
to discard and prune the tree as you go
to make sure that you're not keeping too
many hypotheses on each step so this
process of finding your best sequence is
also called decoding so here's an
overview of how that works for SMT this
is an example where you have this German
sentence that translates to he does not
go home and you can see that there's
some kind of phrase to phrase alignments
here so an overview of how this decoding
would work in SMT is that you kind of
consider lots of different hypotheses
for how you might translate these
individual words and then you build it
up to consider how you might translate
individual phrases and the phrases get
bigger so for example you can see that
on the top right if it's not too small
you can see that the
the German word for house could be
translated into the English word house
or home or chamber and so on so we
consider all of these different
hypotheses and look into how we might
put those together to translate the
phrases but you don't keep all of them
all the time you get rid of the ones and
a too low probability so this can also
be depicted as a kind of a tree where
you are exploring different options
you're searching through this space of
options but then you prune the tree as
you go so I know this is a very very
high-level description of how decoding
might work and in fact later in this
lecture you're going to see a detailed
explanation of how this kind of decoding
works for neural machine translation ok
so what's our overview of statistical
machine translation was it effective
so SMT was a huge research field from
the 1990s to about maybe 2013 and the
best systems during this time were
extremely complex they were extremely
sophisticated and impressive systems and
SMT made the best machine translation
systems in the world but they were very
complex so for example you know there
were hundreds of important details that
we haven't mentioned here at all there
were many many techniques to make it
more complex and more sophisticated than
what I've described today in particular
the system's has to have many separately
designed sub components so we really saw
how you break down the translation model
into two separate parts but there was
you know many more sub components than
that and often they had to be learned
separately this meant that engineers had
to do a lot of feature engineering you
had to design features to capture the
particular language phenomena that you
were interested in so this meant that
they had to require a lot of compiling
and maintaining of extra resources and
in fact you had to have different
resources for different languages so the
work kind of multiplied the more
languages you had an example of this is
he had to have tables of equivalent
phrase that's so for example if you're
doing French and English translation
then they would be collecting these
phrases of sorry these tables of phrases
that are considered similar and those
would learn from the data but this was a
lot of information that had to be stored
and maintained so overall this was just
a lot
human efforts maintained and again yes
you had to put more human effort in if
you wanted to learn an SMT system for a
new language pair okay are there any
questions here about SMT okay so moving
on that's SMT now we're going to move on
to section two of this lecture so I want
to take you back to the year 2014 for a
dramatic reenactment of what happened in
the world of machine translation
research so in 2014 something very
dramatic happens and that thing that
happened is called neural machine
translation and I think it looks a
little bit like this if I'm not being
too dramatic so what is neural machine
translation the idea is that nmt is a
way to do machine translation but using
just a single neural network and the
neural network architectures that they
use is called sequence to sequence or
something's just called seek to seek and
it involves two RN ends so it's called
sequence of sequence because you're
mapping one sequence to the other the
source sentence for the target sentence
and you need to our lens basically to
handle those two different sentences
alright let's look at a diagram to see
what sequence of sequences in detail so
we start off with our source sentence
and we're going to use our example from
before in monterrey which means you hit
me with a pipe so we feed this into our
encoder RNN and this is as you've seen
before I've drawn a unidirectional RNN
but this could be bi-directional it also
could be multi-layer it could be vanilla
or it could be lsdm and so on another
thing to note is that we are passing
word embeddings into this encoder RNN
but I'm just not explicitly depicting
that step okay so the idea of the
encoder RNN is that it's going to
produce some kind of encoding of this
source sentence so for now let's assume
that the encoding of the source sentence
is going to be the final hidden state of
this encoder RNN so what happens next is
we pass this encoding of the saw
sentence we pass it over to the decoder
which is going to translate into English
so the decoder RNN is a language model
in particular it's a conditional
language model like we talked about last
time
so it's conditional because it's going
to produce the target sentence but
conditions on this encoding and the
encoding is that vector that has the
orange box around it so how does this
work we start off by feeding the start
token into the decoder and then we can
get the first state of the decoder
because we're using the encoding of the
source sentence as the initial hidden
state for the decoder so then we get our
first output from the decoder which is a
probability distribution of what word
might come next and let's suppose that
we take the alchemax over that and then
that gets us the words heat which is in
this case is correct because that's
probably the word you should start with
okay so then we just take the word heat
and then we feed it back into the
decoder on the next step and then we do
the same thing again we take our mags
and we get a new word and we get he hit
so the idea is that you can continue
doing this operation and in that way
you're going to generate your target
sentence which will be something like he
hit me with a pipe and you stop once
your decoder produces the end token so
an important thing to note here is that
this picture is showing you what happens
at test time this shows you how to
generate text this isn't what happens
during training I'll show you what
happens during training later but this
thing with the the pink dotted arrows
where you feed the word back in this is
what you do to generate text at test
time any questions on this Oh another
thing I should note is that you need two
separate sets of word embeddings right
you need word embeddings for french
words and you need English word
embeddings that's kind of two separate
sets two separate vocabularies yeah okay
so as a side note this architecture
called sequence of sequence is actually
pretty versatile it's not just a machine
translation architecture you can phrase
quite a few NLP tasks as sequence to
sequence tasks so for example a
summarization is a Seikh
sequence tasks because in goes your long
text and out comes your short text
dialogue can be seek seek
because in goes the previous utterance
and out comes your next utterance
pausing can even be thought of as a
sequence a sequence task because you
could say in goes the input text and the
output pause is going to be expressed as
a sequence this might not be the best
way to depositing but it is a way you
can try
lastly you can even do something like
code generation so suppose you want to
build a system that takes some kind of
natural language input such as sum up
the numbers from 1 to 10 and then it
outputs let's say some Python code that
says some open brackets range 10 or
something like that so if you wanted to
train a system to do this you could in a
way view that as a translation task
where you're translating from English to
Python it's a pretty challenging
translation task that probably requires
a lot more logic than just you know
French to English but you can try and
people have tried there are research
papers where people have used seek seek
to do this kind of task ok so to recap a
seat seek is an example of a conditional
language model it's a language model
because the decoder is a language model
that's predicting the next target word
but it's a conditional language model
because it's also conditioning on your
source sentence which is represented by
the encoding of the source sentence so
you could look at you could view it like
this nmt is directly calculating the
probability of the target sentence Y
given this or sentence X so if you look
at this you see that this is just
breaking down the probability of the
sequence Y which we suppose is of length
capital T you can break it down into
being the probability of the first word
of Y given X and then the probability of
the second word of Y given the words
that came before and X and so on so in
fact you can see that each of the terms
in this product on the right those are
probabilities of the next target word
given all the ones so far and also the
source sentence and that's exactly the
conditional probability that your
language model produces so the reason
I'm highlighting this is because if you
remember in SMT we didn't directly learn
the translation model P of Y given X we
broke it down into
smaller components whereas here in nmt
we are directly learning this model and
this is in some ways an advantage
because it's simpler to do you don't
have to learn all of these different
systems and optimize them separately
it's kind of simpler and easier so this
is this is the model that we're learning
the question is how do we train this nmt
system
so hopefully you should already have a
good idea of how this would work given
that we've already seen how you would
train a language model but here are the
details just in case so you get your big
parallel corpus and then let's say you
have your sentence pair from your
parallel corpus so this is what happens
during training you feed your source
sentence into the encoder RNN and then
you feed your target sentence into the
decoder RNN and you're going to pass
over that final hidden state to be the
initial hidden state of the decoder and
then for every step of the decoder RNN
you're going to produce the probability
distribution of what comes next which is
the Y hats and then from those you can
compute your loss and the loss is just
the same as we saw for unconditional
language models it's the cross entropy
or you could also say negative log
likelihood of the true next word so for
example on those selected ones the loss
is the negative log probability of the
correct next word and then as before
we're going to average all of these
losses to get the total loss for the
example so thing you might notice people
saying in for example research papers is
this phrase end to end and this is an
example of learning a system end to end
and what we mean by this is that the
back propagation is happening and one
end is is the losses the loss functions
and the other end I guess is kind of
like the beginning of the encode RNN the
point is that you back propagation flows
throughout the entire system and you
learn the entire system with respect to
this single loss
how do you have the loss of it wouldn't
get to intrude like the question is if
the decoder RNN outputs the end token
too early then how can you measure the
loss on the words that came after that
so this is the difference between
training time and test time which is
pretty confusing so during training we
have this picture where you feed the
token back in so in this scenario once
you produce ends then you have to stop
because you can't feed end in as the
input on next step but in training you
don't feed the thing that you produced
into the next step during training you
feed the target sentence from the corpus
so like the gold target sentence into
the model so no matter what the the
decoder predicts on a step you kind of
you don't use that for anything other
than computing loss any other questions
yeah you would probably get into ends
that of maybe training an encoder well
English model and then maybe training a
decoder separately and putting them
together the question is is there a
reason why you would want to train end
to end when for example you might want
to train the encoder and the decoder
separately so I think people view
training end-to-end is favorable because
the idea is that you can optimize the
system as a whole you might think that
if you optimize the parts separately
then when you put them together they
will not be optimal together necessarily
so if possible directly optimizing the
thing that you care about about with
respect to all of the parameters is more
likely to succeed however there is a
notion of pre training and as you said
maybe you'd want to learn your decoder
RNN as a kind of a language model and
unconditional language model by itself
and that's something that people do you
might learn a very strong language model
and then use that to initialize your
decoder RNN and then fine-tune it on
your task that's a valid thing you might
try to you always be honest or for
Worster
always getting out the question is is
the length of the source sentence and
the length of the target sentence fixed
so for example is the source sentence
always length four no that's definitely
not true because in your parallel corpus
you're going to have sentences of all
lengths so this is more kind of an
implementation or a practicality
question the idea is that this is what
you mathematically want to be computing
during training for each example and
you're going to have batches of examples
but the question is how do you actually
implement that in in practice so what
you usually do just because it's easier
to assume that your batch is this kind
of even sized tensor where everything is
the same length is you pad any short
sentences up to some predefined maximum
length or maybe the length of the
maximum example in your batch and then
you make sure that you don't use any
hidden states that came from the padding
that would be kind of Universal between
similar languages or something like that
okay so the question I think is it seems
like sometimes you wouldn't want to
Train things end to end and there are
circumstances in which you might want to
Train things separately and you
mentioned for example having different
languages mapped to each other so this
is a totally valid point and in fact so
far we've kind of assumed that you want
to learn language a to language B as a
pair right and that's different to
languages language C or even language B
to language a and that does mean e have
kind of N squared many systems in the
number of languages we're considering so
yeah that's actually a valid idea and
this is something that people have
researched the idea that maybe you could
have a kind of mix and match with your
encoders and decoders and you could try
to train a kind of general-purpose let's
say English decoder and then match it up
with your difference encoders but this
is I think very complex to train and to
make sure that they all work together
but that is certainly something that
people have done let me just check on
the time ok let's take one more question
yep so that's important but they also
come from the same purpose that we are
training out
the question is does the word embedding
also come from the corpus that you're
training on so I think there's a few
options just as we saw with language
models you could download pre-trained
words vectors like word tobacco or glove
and you could use those and then you can
either kind of freeze them or you could
fine-tune them as part of the entry and
training or you could just initialize
your word vectors as you know close to
zero random and then learn them from
scratch all right okay moving on so now
we understand how you would train a
neural machine translation system and we
talked briefly about how you might do
decoding or generation so what I showed
you before is something called greedy
decoding which is this idea that on each
step you just choose the augments the
top one best words and then you feed
that in on the next step so this is
called greedy decoding because you're
just taking the best the best option
that you can see right now and then you
don't really have a way to go back so
can anyone see a problem with this
method
maybe I've kind of given it away yeah so
you said too expensive I guess I mean it
is expensive in that you have to do a
sequence and the sequence is usually
worse than something you can do in
parallel but I suppose maybe what's
wrong with the greediness can anyone
suggest what's wrong with the greedy
nuts yeah yeah when you take an
alternative not necessarily going to
give you the org max over the entire
sentence that's exactly right that's
kind of what what greediness means so in
practice this might give you something
like this we're trying to translate our
running example sentence and then let's
suppose on the first step we say he and
then we say he hit and then he we say he
hit a oh no that wasn't right that
wasn't the best thing to choose but we
kind of have no way to go back now right
we just have to continue and try to make
the best of it after saying he hit a
which isn't going to work out well so
that's the main problem with greedy
decoding there's kind of no way to
backtrack no way to go back so how can
we fix this and this relates back to
what I told you earlier about how we
might use a kind of searching algorithm
to do decoding in SMT
but first you might think exhaustive
search is a good idea well probably not
because it's still a ballad if the same
reasons as before so if you did want to
do exhaustive search and search through
the space of all possible French
translations then you would be again
trying to consider which Y maximizes
this product of all of these individual
probability distributions so as before
if you try to do this then on each step
T of the decoder you're going to be
having to track V to the power of T
possible partial translations where V is
your vocabulary size so here when I say
partial translation I just mean kind of
you know like half of a sentence so far
or something like that
so of course this exponential in V
complexity is just far too expensive so
yes we're going to use some kind of
search algorithm and particularly we're
going to use a beam search decoding so
the core idea of beam search decoding is
that on each step of the decoder you're
going to be keeping track of the K most
probable partial translations and we
call partial translations hypotheses
because we're kind of tracking multiple
of them and we're not sure which one is
best so we're thinking about several
here K is a integer and we call this the
beam size and in practice for nmt this
is usually maybe five to ten so you can
think of K kind of as how big is your
search space at any one time so if you
increase K then you're going to be
considering more different options on
each step and you might hope that this
will mean that you get the best quality
solution in the end though of course it
will be more expensive so I said that we
want to keep track of the cave most
probable partial translations that is
hypotheses so this means that we use
some kind of notion of you know how
probable is this hypothesis or what's
its score so the score of a hypothesis
and we're representing that as y1 up to
Y T is just its log probability so the
log probability of this partial
translation according to the language
model can be broken down as we saw
before into the sum of the individual
log probabilities of the words given
everything that came before
it's if it's not obvious these schools
are all negative because we're taking
log of a over number between zero and
one
and a higher score is better yes because
you want a higher probability of of the
hypothesis according to the language
model so the idea is that we're going to
use this score and the search algorithm
to search for high-scoring hypotheses
and we're going to track the top K on
each step so I'm going to show you a
detailed example in a moment but the
important things to know are that beam
search is not guaranteed to find an
optimal solution exhaustive search the
one where you enumerate enumerate all V
to the T possible translations that is
guaranteed to find the optimal solution
but it's just completely infeasible
because it's so expensive so beam search
is not guaranteed to find the optimal
solution but it is much more efficient
an exhaustive search of course ok so
here's an example of beam search
decoding in action so let's suppose the
beam size equals K is 2 and then as a
reminder we have this is the score that
you apply to a partial hypothesis a
partial translation which has a
hypothesis so we start off with our
starting token and the idea is that
we're going to compute the probability
distribution of what word might come
next so having computed that probability
distribution using our CT model then we
just take the top K that is top two
possible options so let's suppose at the
top two of the words he and I so the
idea is that we can compute the score of
these two hypotheses by using the
formula above it's just the log
probability of this word given the
contact so far so here let's say that he
has a score of minus 0.7 and AI has a
score of minus 0.9 this means that he is
currently in the better one okay so what
we do is we have our two our K
hypotheses and then for each of those we
find the top K words that could come
next can we calculate their scores so
this means that for both he and I we
find the top two words that could come
next and to each of these four
possibilities the score of the
hypothesis is equal to the log
probability of this new word given the
context
plus the score so far because you can
accumulate this sum of log probabilities
you don't have to compute it from
scratch each time so here you can see
that we have these four possibilities
and that the top two scores are minus
one point six and minus one point seven
so this means that hits and was are the
two best ones so the idea is that of
these K squared equals four i policies
we're just going to keep the K equals
two top ones and then we just keep doing
the same thing for these two we expand
to get the two next ones and then of
those we compute the scores and then we
keep the two best ones and discard the
others and then of those we expand so we
keep doing this again again expanding
and then just keeping the top K and
expanding like this until you get some
kind of finished translation I'm going
to tell you more in a moment about what
exactly the stopping criterion is but
let's suppose that we stopped here
looking at the four hypotheses that we
have on the far right the one with the
top score is the top pi one with minus
four point three so let's suppose that
we're going to stop now when we decide
that this is the topic or thesis then
all we need to do is just backtrack
through this tree in order to find the
full translation which is he hit me with
a pie all right so let me tell you more
detail about how exactly we decide when
to stop so if you remember in greedy
decoding usually we just keep decoding
until the model produces the end token
so for example this means that your
model is actually producing the sequence
I guess it doesn't produce start you
give it start but then it produces the
sequence he hit me with a pie and so the
problem in beam touch decoding is that
you're considering all these different
hypotheses K different hypotheses at
once and the thing is those hypotheses
might produce n tokens at different
times so there's no one obvious place to
stop so what we do in practice is when a
hypothesis produces the end token then
we regard this hypothesis as complete
and we kind of place it aside we have a
collection of completed hypotheses so we
kind of take it out of beam search we no
longer keep exploring it because it's
finished and we yeah place it aside and
you continue exploring other hypotheses
with means search
so the remaining question is when do you
stop doing beam search when do you stop
iterating through this algorithm so
there's multiple possible stopping
criterions but two common ones are you
might say we're going to stop doing beam
search once we reach time step T where T
is some predefined threshold you choose
so you might say we're gonna stop being
searched after 30 steps because we don't
want any output sentence is longer than
30 words for example or you might say
we're going to stop doing beam search
and once we've collected at least n
completed hypotheses so you might say I
want at least 10 complete translations
before I stopped doing beam search okay
so what's the final thing you have to do
we finish doing beam search and we have
this collection of completed hypotheses
we want to choose the top one the one
that we're going to use as our
translation so how do we select the top
one that has the highest score you might
think this is a simple given that all of
these hypotheses already have scores
attached but if we just look at this
formula again for what the score is of
each hypothesis can anyone see a problem
with this if we have our set of
hypotheses and then we're choosing the
top one based on the one that has the
best score can anyone see a problem yeah
yes so the answer was you're going to
lose of choosing the shortest one the
problem is that longer hypotheses have
lower scores in general because you're
multiplying more probabilities you're
guessing a smaller a smaller value or I
guess if we're adding log from the teams
I'm gonna get some more negative
evaluation so it's not quite you'll
definitely choose the shortest
hypothesis because if you could overall
have a lower score but there's
definitely going to be a bias towards
shorter translation which is well in
general has so the way you can fix this
is pretty simple you just normalize by
length so instead of using the score
that we have above you're going to use
the score divided by society and
something of that hypothesis and then
you use this to select your top one any
questions on this yeah so that it is a
pie it is possible to be trained with
the ant okay yeah yes so you train with
the N token if that's your question
because the whole point is you're
relying on your language model your
decoder to produce the end token in
order to know when to stop so you need
to train it to produce the N token by
giving it examples of training sentences
with n tokens yeah
the question is why don't we use this
normalized score the one at the bottom
the screen during being searched in the
first place so the reason why that's not
necessary you could but it's not
necessary is because during beam search
we only ever compare the scores of
hypotheses that have the same length
right so on each of these steps where we
look at let's say the top K Squared's
and we want to choose which ones are the
top k we're comparing the scores of four
different hypotheses that are of length
1 2 3 4 5 so it's true that these scores
are getting lower and lower burnt in the
same way because they're all thanks 5
right now ok so we now understand how
you would train in an empty system and
how would you you would use your trained
an empty system to generate your
translations using let's say beam search
so let's take a step back and think
about what are the overall advantages of
nmt in comparison to SMT so the first
advantage is just better performance
energy systems tend to give better
output than SMT systems in several ways
one is that the output often tends to be
more fluent this is probably because nmt
this is probably because our n ends are
particularly good at learning language
modules as you learned last week another
way that they're better
is they often use the contacts better
that is they're better at conditioning
on the source sentence and using that to
change the outfit another way that
better is they often are more able to
generalize what they learn about phrases
and how to translate them so for example
if it sees an example of how to
translate a certain source phrase and
then later it sees a slightly different
version of that source phrase it's more
able to generalize what it learns about
the first phrase then SMT system as well
another big advantage of nmt systems
compared to SMT that we talked about
before is that it's a single neural
network that can be optimized end to end
and the advantage here I suppose is
primarily simplicity and convenience so
there's no sub components that need to
be individually optimized another big
advantage is that it requires much less
human engineering efforts when I told
you earlier about all the different
things that people had to do to build
big powerful SMT systems there's
relatively less engineering effort Venom
T and then C is certainly not easy but
it's is less complicated than SMT in
particular there's no feature
engineering you don't have to define
what features of linguistic phenomena
that you want to capture you can mostly
just view it as a sequence of words
although there are different views on
that lastly a great thing about nmt is
that you can use pretty much the same
method for all language pets so if
you've you know built your french
english translation system and now you
want to build a spanish to english one
you can probably use basically the same
architecture in the same method as long
as you can go find a big enough parallel
corpus of spanish to english alright so
what are the disadvantages of nmt
remaining so compared to SMT there are
some disadvantages
one is that NM t is less interpretable
what i mean by this is you feed in your
sole sentence into the neural network
and then it feeds out some target
sentence and you don't really have any
way to figure out why that happens right
so in particular if the target sentence
could contain some kind of error you
can't really look at the neurons and
understand what happened it's pretty
hard to attribute errors this means that
nmt systems are pretty hard
debug so by comparison SMT systems were
more interpretable in that you had all
of these different sub components that
were doing different jobs and you were
more able to look at those they weren't
you know neurons often would be you know
probabilities of certain words given
other words and so on and you know
that's by no means easy to interpret but
it was at least more interpretable than
nmt another disadvantage is nmt is
pretty difficult to control so for
example if your nmt system is doing a
particular error it's not very easy for
you the the programmer to specify some
kind of rule or guideline that you want
the NNT system to follow so for example
if you want to say I want to always
translate this word in this way
when when this other thing is present
like that's not particularly easy to to
impose as a rule on the nmt system
because you can't easily control what
it's doing on a step by step basis so
sometimes you have some kind of
post-processing rules you might try to
do but overall you can't it's harder
than you'd expect to try to impose a
fairly simple rule so this means you
have some kind of safety concerns in
fact because let's say you know you
don't want your nmt system to say bad
things right it's pretty hard to
actually put these controls in place to
stop it from saying these things you
don't want it to say I mean on the level
of maybe just never saying particular
bad words then sure you can remove them
from their vocabulary but overall
they're pretty hard to control and we're
actually going to see some examples of
nmt systems being you know doing things
that their designers certainly didn't
intend okay so how do we evaluate MT
every good and I'll be task needs to
have an automatic metrics so that we can
measure our progress so the most
commonly used evaluation metric for MT
is called blue and that stands for
bilingual evaluation under study so the
main idea is that blue is going to
compare the translation that's produced
by your machine translation system it's
going to compare that to one or maybe
several human written translations of
the same sentence and then it's going to
compute a similar
a score that's based on Ngram precision
so when I say Ngram precision I mean
you're going to look at all the one two
three and four grams that appear in your
machine written translation and your
human written translation and then Ngram
precision is basically saying for all of
the engrams that appeared in the machine
written translation how many of those
appeared in you know at least one of the
human written translations another thing
you need to add to blue is a brevity
penalty so you're saying you get a lower
blue score if your system translation is
significantly shorter than all of the
human written translations and the
reason why you need to add this is
because Ngram precision alone doesn't
really punish using fewer words so you
might try to maximize Ngram precision by
being very conservative and writing
short sentences that only contain was
that you're really sure about and then
you get a good precision score but this
doesn't make a good translation because
you're probably missing a bunch of
information that you needed to translate
from the source sentence so that's why
you need to add a brevity penalty so
overall blue is very useful because we
need an automatic metric in order to
measure progress you can't measure
progress on human evaluation alone
because it takes too long to compute but
of course it's pretty imperfect so for
example you can think about how there
are many ways many valid ways to
translate a sentence at the very
beginning of this lecture I asked how do
we translate that sentence by Rousseau
and there are at least a few different
options that came up so if there's many
valid ways to translate a sentence how
does blue recognize that blue is
rewarding sentences that have a high end
gram overlap with one or some of the
human written translations but if you
write one your fuel model writes one
valid translation and the humans wrote a
different valid translation and they
don't have high Engram overlap then blue
is going to give you a low score so
you're going to learn about blue and
detail in assignment four and in fact
the sign before has a full description
mathematical description of what the
blue score is so I'm not going to tell
you about that now yeah so you're going
to think about blue and the ways in
which it's imperfect for useful yeah
one Engram vo on the one hand is
equivalent so what a 180 gram be a
one-to-one equivalency could have one be
a one-to-one equivalency I'm not sure I
answer the question are you asking about
alignment or something else how they're
doing Engram checks is it doing all
Engram permutations or is doing like
window size of one well I guess one one
grams it doesn't make a difference
because you can't permute of one gram
okay so you're asking for example four
grams are they checking whether this
exact sequence of four appeared or any
permutation a bit it's exact sequences
so by definition and grams are sequences
where the order matters okay all right
so that's how you evaluate machine
translation so now you can understand
this metric of how we evaluate our
progress on machine translation I can
show you this graph and you might
understand a little what it means so
this is a Bob plot which shows in a
nutshell how nmt changed the machine
translation landscape in just a few
years so in this plot we've got blue
score is the y-axis and you have two
different types of SMT which is the red
and the dark blue bar plots and what's
happening is in 2015
neural empty enters the scene for the
first time and it isn't doing as well as
SMT and then the next year it's suddenly
outperforming SMT and here these are
blue scores on some particular fixed
data set like a shared task that many
people were submitting systems for so
the main thing to notice here is that
the progress that was being made by SMT
systems was you know a fairly gentle
increase in blue year by year and then
in just one year nmt arrives and is
suddenly doing much more rapid progress
so I think this justifies why the
picture of the meaty or maybe isn't too
dramatic here so you could in fact cool
nmt the biggest success story of NLP and
deep learning because if you think about
the history of this nmt went from being
a fringe research activity in 2014 to
being actually the leading standard
method for machine translation in the
wild in 2016
in particular in 2014 the first seek
seek paper was published and in 2016
Google Translate switches from SMT to
nmt this is a pretty remarkable
turnaround for just two years so this is
amazing not just because it was a quick
turnaround but also if you think about
the level of human effort involves these
SMT systems for example the Google
Translate SMT system was built by
Darla's hundreds of engineers over many
years and this this SMT system was
outperformed by an energy system that
was trained by you know relatively few
like a handful of engineers in a few
months so I'm not I'm not diminishing
how difficult it is to build an empty
systems and certainly I'm sure
Google's nmt system today is built by
more than a handful of engineers in a
few months I'm sure it's a very big
operation now but when nmt began to
outperform SMT it was pretty remarkable
how I was able to do that based on the
amount of effort involved
yeah it's getting there we know that
there are some disadvantages of nmt even
in comparison to SMT is there any work
on combining the two so yes I think
there is there's a lot of nmt research
ongoing and in particular people
sometimes focus on these particular
shortcomings and there's a lot of work
in kind of taking techniques and ideas
and wisdom from the many decades of SMT
research and then integrating them into
the new nmt paradigm so yes
okay so it's machine translation solved
can we all go home I think the answer is
clearly no nmt definitely is not doing
machine translation perfectly so just to
highlight some of the difficulties that
remain with nm t1 is a severe capillary
words this is a kind of basic problem
but it's pretty tricky you know what do
you do if you're trying to translate a
sentence that contains a word that it's
not in your sauce vocabulary or what if
you're trying to produce a word that's
not in your target vocabulary there's
certainly been lots of work on doing
this and you're going to hear later in
the class how you might try to attack
this with for example sub word modeling
can make it easier but this is a remit
this is a significant problem
another one is domain mismatch so let's
suppose that you train your machine
translation system on a bunch of fairly
formal texts like let's say Wikipedia or
something like that but then you try to
deploy it to translate in formal texts
like people chatting on Twitter or
something then often you'll find that it
doesn't perform very well on this
different domain because you've got a
domain mismatch so that's quite a big
problem another one is maintaining
context over longer text so everything
we've talked about so far has assumes
that you're just translating a single
sentence to a single sentence and
there's no other wider context but you
know if you want to use a machine
translation system to translate a whole
news article or maybe even a book then
you're probably going to want to use the
context that came in previous sentences
in order to translate things correctly
in the current sentence so this is an
active area of research how can you get
an energy system to condition on larger
pieces of context without it becoming
too expensive and so on another
difficulty is low resource language
pairs everything we've talked about so
far has assumed that you have access to
a very large parallel corpus but what if
you don't what if you're trying to
translate to or from a language that has
relatively little text available online
for example so that could be pretty
difficult here are a few examples of
machine translation screwing up with the
specific specific errors so here's an
example of how common-sense is really
difficult
for nmt systems on the left we have the
English phrase paper jam which means
when your printer gets jammed up with
paper and it's all tangled inside and
then on the right we have a very literal
translation of that into Spanish and is
essentially saying Jam edible Jam made
of paper which clearly isn't the right
interpretation so here we have an empty
system that's just doing very literal
translation and clearly doesn't have any
notion of common sense you can't make
jam from paper here's another example
nmt can pick up biases in the training
data we already talked about this at the
the words embedding level the
representation of words but it can also
be a problem at the you know the
sentence level when you're translating
things so here in this example on the
Left we have two sentences in Malay that
roughly mean they works in US and they
work as a programmer the point is on the
left there is no information about
gender in the pronouns but when it gets
translated to English then we've
suddenly got gender coming out of
nowhere she works in US and he works as
a programmer this is likely happening
because in our training day said we had
more examples of female nurses and male
programmers so you can understand why
from a machine learning maximizing the
objective point of view the English
language model has learned to do that
but the problem here is this isn't good
machine translation here the system is
making up information that was not
present in the source sentence so this
is certainly an error that the machine
translation shouldn't be doing because
it's just simply inaccurate and even
worse it's propagating gender roles
here's another pretty weird example
what is happening here on the Left we
have a nonsense sentence that's just
kind of a syllable repeated and we're
supposedly translating from Somali and
then we're asking to translate this into
English and then we're guessing this out
of nowhere as the name of the lords was
written in the Hebrew language it was
written in the language of the Hebrew
nation and you might be thinking where
on earth did that come from and in fact
this got reported in the media as you
know if Google Translate wants to
convert you to its religion or whatever
so for sure it is very startling but the
thing is there's actually quite a
reasonable explanation so what's going
on here is that often for low-resource
languages such as for example somali one
of the best resources of parallel text
is the bible so you train for example
smiley's english using the bible as a
training text maybe among other texts
okay so that's the first puzzle piece
but the other the other puzzle piece is
the nonsensical input so when the input
isn't really Somali or any kind of text
right it's just the same syllable over
and over then the nmt system doesn't
really have anything sensible to
condition on it's basically nonsense
it's just noise so what does the nmt
system do right it can't really use the
economy condition on the source sentence
so what it does is it just uses the
English language model right you can
think of it as like the English language
model the decoder RNN just kind of goes
into autopilot and starts generating
random text kind of like we saw last
week when we saw a language model
trained on Obama speeches or Harry
Potter would just generate text in that
style that's kind of what's happening
here with the Bible because we don't
have any useful information from the
sentence on the left so this is an
example why neural machine translation
in particular makes these kinds of
errors because the system is
unintelligible so you don't know that
this is going to happen until it happens
and perhaps Google didn't know this was
going to happen until that happened and
it got reported so this is one downside
of uninterpreted bility is that really
weird effects can happen and you don't
see them coming and it's not always even
easy to explain why they happened yep
the question is what happens if you did
translate from Irish I suppose that's
the part where Google tries to auto
detect the language maybe it thinks that
a gag is more like Irish and Samadhi I
imagine if you did put Irish to English
there's probably more training data for
Irish English so maybe it wouldn't be so
Bible focus yeah and there's a lot of
examples of these online where you do
different kinds of nonsense syllables
and different languages so there's a lot
of challenges remaining in nmt and the
research continues
so nmt I think remains one of the
flagship tasks for NLP deep learning and
in fact nmt research has pioneered many
of the successful innovations of NLP
deep learning in general so today in
2019 NT research continues to thrive
there's still many many papers published
all the time on nmt and in fact
researchers have found lots of
improvements to the fairly vanilla seek
seek models I've shown you today but in
fact there is one improvement that is so
integral to seek to seek that you could
regard it as the new vanilla and that's
the improver we're going to learn about
today and it's called attention ok so
section 3 is on attention what is
attention first I'm going to motivate
why we need this thing called attention
so let's look at this diagram that we
saw before of sequence a sequence and
remember when we assumed that this
encoding of the source sentence the the
one in the orange box is going to
represent the whole sentence can anyone
volunteer a problem you can see with
this architecture in particular perhaps
a problem with this idea that that
single vector is the encoding of the
sole sentence yep no it doesn't you're
only looking at one word and that word
could have
know what's going on so you can't figure
out which one okay so the answer is
something like you're only looking at
one word to me like the last word for
soul functions and you're not seeing
more information yeah it's um it's it's
something like that any other it is yep
yeah you might have lost information
especially if it was longer than four
words right I think these are different
ways of saying a similar idea which is
that we have a kind of informational
bottleneck we're forcing all of the
information about the source sentence to
be captured in this single vector
because that's the only thing that gets
given to the decoder if some information
about source sentence is in that back
tooth and there's no way the decode is
going to be able to translate it
correctly so this is the this is an
informational bottleneck it's putting
kind of too much pressure on this single
vector to be a good representation of
the encoder so this is the motivation
for attention attention is a neural
technique and it provides a solution to
the bottleneck problem the core idea is
that on each step of the decoder you're
going to use a direct connection to the
end coder to focus on a particular part
of the source sequence so first I'm
going to show you what attention is via
a diagram so that's kind of an intuitive
explanation and then I'm going to show
you the equations later so here's how
each sequence the sequence with
attention works so on the first step of
our decoder we have our first decoder
hidden state so what we do is we take
the dot products between that decoder
hidden state and the first encoder
hidden state and then we get something
called an attention score which I'm
representing by a dot so that's a scaler
and in fact we take the dot product
between the decoded state and all of the
encoder hidden states so this means that
we get one attention score one scalar
for each of these source words
effectively so next what we do is we
take those four numbers scores and we
apply the softmax
distribution the softmax function to
them and then we get a probability
distribution so here I'm going to
represent that probability distribution
as a bar chart and we call this the
attention
distribution and this one sums up to one
so here you can see that most of the
probability mass is on the first word
and that kind of makes sense because our
first word essentially means he and
we're going to be producing the word he
first in our target sentence so once
we've got this attention distribution
we're going to use it to produce
something called the attention output so
the idea is that the attention output is
a weighted sum of the encoder hidden
States and the weighting is the
attention distributions so I've got
these dotted arrows that go from the
attention distribution to the attention
output probably there should be dotted
arrows also from the encoder RNN but
that's hard to depict but the idea is
that you're summing up these encoder RNN
hidden states but you're going to weight
each one according to how much attention
distribution it has on it so this means
that your attention output which is a
single vector is going to be mostly
containing information from the hidden
States that had high attention in this
case it's going to be mostly information
from the first hidden state so after you
do this you're going to use the
attention output to influence your
prediction of the next word so what you
usually do is you concatenate the
attention output with your decoder
hidden States and then use that kind of
concatenated pair in the way you would
have used the decoder hidden state alone
before so that way you can get your
probability distribution Y hat one of
what's coming next so as before you can
use that to sample your next word so on
the next steps you just do the same
thing again you've got your second
decoder hidden States again you take dot
product with all of the encoder ten
states you take softmax a without to get
the attention distribution and here you
can see the attention distribution is
difference we're putting more attention
on the the word on toss a because we're
about to produce the word hit but we're
also attending a little bit to the
second word R because that's telling us
that hit is a past tense so a cool thing
that's happening here is we're getting
soft alignment if you remember when we
looked at alignment and SMT systems
it was mostly this hard binary thing was
on/off either these words are aligned or
they're not here you have a much more
flexible soft notion of alignments where
each word kind of has a distribution
over the
corresponding words in the sole sentence
so another thing to note kind of a side
note is that sometimes we take the
attention output from the previous
hidden state and we kind of feed it into
the decoder again along with the usual
word so that would mean you take the
attention output from the first step and
kind of concatenate it to the word
vector for he and then use it in the
decoder the reason for this is sometimes
it's useful to have this information
from the attention on the previous step
on the next step so I'm telling you this
because this is something we do in
assignment 4 and it's a fairly common
technique but also sometimes people do
into it okay so um the easier is that
you just do this attention computation
on every step and on each step you're
going to be attending to different
things so in our example on this third
step we look at M ' which means me when
we produce me and then on the last three
we're probably mostly just gonna be
looking at this fertile word on today to
produce hit me with a pipe I'm gonna
keep going because I don't have a lot of
time so here are the equations to
describe attention I think it's probably
easier to look at these in your own time
layer rather than look at them in the
lecture now but these are the equations
that essentially say the same thing as
what the diagram just said so you have
your encoder hidden states H 1 up to H n
and then on time step T of the decoder
we also have a decoder hidden state s T
so you're going to get the attention
scores which we're going to call et by
taking the dot product of your decoder
in state with each of the encode in
States and that gives you a vector of
same length as the encoder sentence
because you've got one score per source
word next you take softmax over these
scores to get attention distribution
that sums up to 1 and we call that alpha
and then you use alpha to take a
weighted sum of the encoded hidden
states and that gives you your attention
output so the attention output which we
call a is a vector that's the same size
as your encoder hidden States
lastly you take your attention output a
and then you concatenate it with your
decoder hidden state and then proceed
with that as you would have before in
the no attention model
so attention if it's not clear is pretty
cool it has a number of advantages so
one advantage is that attention just
significantly improves nmt performance
and the main reason why it improves it
is because it turns out it's super
useful to allow the decoder to focus on
certain parts of the source sentence
when it's translating and you can see
why this makes sense right because
there's a very natural notion of
alignment and if you can focus on the
specific word or words that you're
translating you can probably do a better
job another reason why attention is cool
is that it solves the bottle no problem
we were now seeing that the problem with
having a single vector that has to
represent the entire source sentence and
that's the only way information can pass
from encode to decoder means that if
that encoding isn't very good then
you're not going to do well so by
contrast in with attention the decoder
can look directly at the encoder and the
sauce sentence and translate without the
bottleneck another great thing about
attention is that it helps with the
ranch ingredient problem especially if
your sentences are quite long the reason
why attention helps is because you have
these direct connections between the
decoder and the encoder kind of over
many time steps so it's like a shortcut
connection and just as we learned last
time about skip connections being useful
for reducing banished ingredients here
it's the same notion we have these
long-distance direct connections that
help the gradients flow better another
great thing about tension is to provide
some intelligibility if you look at the
attention distribution after you've
produced your translation you can see
what the decoder was focusing on on each
step so for example if we run our system
and we translate our running example
here then we can produce a plot kind of
like this that shows the attention
distribution so here dock means high
attention and white means low attention
so you might see something like this
where it was it was focusing on the
different words and different stats and
this is basically the same kind of plot
that we had earlier with the hard notion
of alignments in SMT except that we are
we have more flexibility to have a more
soft version of alignment like for
example when we produce the English word
hits perhaps we were mostly looking at
non tart a but we're also looking a
little bit at a so this means that we're
getting alignment for free and the
reason I say for
is because when you remember the SMT
systems the whole point there is that
you had to learn an alignment system
deliberately and separately you had to
define the notion of alignment you had
to define the model of calculating what
the probability of different alignments
were and trainers whereas here we never
told the nmt system about alignments we
never explicitly train an alignment
system we never had a loss function that
tells you how good your alignment was we
just gave the nmt system the apparatus
to do something like alignment and told
it to maximize the the cross-entropy
loss for doing machine translation and
then the network just learned alignment
by itself I think this is the coolest
thing about the tension is that it's
learned some structure in a somewhat
unsupervised way okay so in the last few
minutes I'm just going to generalize the
notion of attention because it turns out
the attention is actually a very general
deep learning technique that you can
apply in lots of different circumstances
so you've seen that attention is a great
way to improve the sequence to sequence
model for MT but you can actually use
attention for other architectures that
aren't seek to seek and also tasks that
aren't empty so to understand this I'm
going to somewhat redefine attention to
a more general definition so here's our
more general definition suppose you have
a set of values each of which is a
vector and you also have a single vector
which are calling the query then
attention is a way to compute a weighted
sum of the values but the way you weight
it is dependent on the query so we often
phrase this as saying that the query is
attending to the values the idea being
they have all this information that's in
the values and the query is somehow
determining how it's going to pay
attention to the values so for example
in seek seek the decoder hidden state is
the query the decoder hints date on a
particular time step is the query and is
attending to all the encoded hidden
states which are the values all right
here's that definition again so here's a
way to kind of understand this
intuitively two alternative ways why
does it think of it like this you could
think of it as the weighted sum is like
a selective summary of the information
in the
values and I say selective because your
choice of how much you choose to draw
from each value depends on the attention
distribution so the distribution depends
on the query so the query is determining
how much you're going to select from
different values and this is kind of
similar to LSD m's that we learned about
earlier this week Alice TM is are all
based on the idea of agates that that
defines how much information should come
from different elements and the gate
depends on the context so the strength
of Ellis Siam's came from the idea that
based on the context you decide where
you're going to draw information from
and this is kind of like the same idea
the second way to think about attention
is you could say that it's a way to
obtain a fixed size representation from
an arbitrary set of representations so
when I say arbitrary sets I'm saying you
have this set of vectors called the
values right and you could have ten
values you could have 100 values you
could have any arbitrary number of these
vectors but attention gives you a way to
get a single vector summary of that
which is the attention output using your
query ok so last thing is that there's
actually several variants of attention
and this is something you're going to
look at a little and assignment for so
in our more general setting we've seen
that we have some values in the query
doing attention always involves
computing the attention scores and then
you apply softmax to get the attention
distribution and then you use that
attention distribution to take a
weighted sum so this is always the
outline of how attention works the part
that can be different is this number one
there are multiple ways you can compute
the scores so last slide here are the
different ways you can repeat the scores
so the first one which you've already
seen today is basic dot product
attention and the idea here is that the
score for a particularly a particular
value H I is just the dot products of
the query and that particular value and
in particularly this assumes that the
size of your query vector and the size
of your value vectors has to be the same
because you're taking dot product
another version or
attention is called multiplicative
attention and here the idea is that the
score of your value H I is going to be
this by linear function of your query
and that value so in particular we're
putting this weight matrix in the middle
and that's a learnable parameter you're
learning the best weight matrix make
weight matrix in order to get the scores
the attention scores that are useful the
last one is called additive attention so
what's happening here is that the score
of the value H I is you get it by
applying a linear transformation to both
the value and the query and then you add
them together and then you put them
through a non-linearity like tan H and
then lastly you take that vector and you
take dot product with a weight vector to
give you a single number that is the
score so here you've got two different
weight matrices and also a weight vector
which are the learn about parameters one
thing that's different here is that
there's kind of an additional hyper
browser which is the attention
dimensionality so that's kind of the I
think it's the height of the W 1 and W 2
and it's the length of V right you can
choose what size that dimension is it's
kind of like a hidden layer in the
computation so you can decide how big
you want that intermediate
representation to be okay so I'm not
gonna tell you any more about that
because that's actually one of the
questions in the assignment assignment
for is to think about the relative
advantages and disadvantages of these
models okay so here's a summary of today
it really is the last slide second last
last time but this was last slide so we
learned about the history of MT we
learnt about how in 2014 neural MT
revolutionized Mt we learnt about how
secrets the sequence is the right
architecture for NM T and it uses two RN
ends and lastly we learnt about how
attention is a way to focus on
particular parts of the input alright
thanks